What is aircraft controllability and why
is controllability important to a pilot?
In this video, I'm going to explain that
topic in detail because if you can
understand controllability, it's going
to make you a much better pilot.
Welcome to Free Pilot Training. I'm Josh
and today we're talking about
controllability. Now, a few lessons ago
we talked about controlling the
airplane, but today we're talking about
controllability because that's something
else you should know about. In a
nutshell, controllability simply means
that the aircraft is responsive to the
control inputs that are made by the
pilot. And I don't have to tell you how
scary it is when you move the controls
and the airplane just continues to do
whatever it was doing. On the other
hand, if I was flying an airplane that
had good controllability and I pushed
down on the right rudder pedal, then
that aircraft is going to immediately
yaw to the right. Another example would
be if I rotated my yolk to the left. An
aircraft with good controllability would
immediately roll to the left. In the
last lesson, we talked about stability.
And that's important because stability
directly affects the controllability of
your airplane. In fact, for most
airplanes, when stability decreases, so
will your controllability. This means
that if you want your airplane to do
what you tell it when you move the
controls, the airplane must be stable.
Let's talk about why that is. In the
last lesson, we talked about how the
airplane is balanced on its center of
lift. And then the center of gravity is
placed in front of the center of lift to
make the aircraft noseheavy. And when
the aircraft starts moving through the
air, the tail creates a down force which
moves the apparent center of gravity
back which then balances out the
airplane. A balanced airplane has great
controllability. But what would happen
if we place the center of gravity too
far back or even behind the center of
lift? Yeah, the airplane couldn't
balance on its center of lift anymore,
could it? This means that your airplane
is not going to be stable if it's not
balanced properly. And this means that
the airplane will be much more difficult
to control as well. Now, you might be
wondering how the center of gravity
could be too far back. This can be
caused by a few things, but in a small
aircraft, this can be caused by putting
too much baggage in the cargo
compartment, which sits behind the
center of lift. Or if you have a really
fat passenger like your mom and she sits
in the back seat behind the center of
lift, then this could cause your center
of gravity to be aft of its allowable
limits. Because most of the back seats
in these airplanes are behind the center
of lift. Keep in mind, an airplane is
going to be more difficult to control
when the center of gravity is after of
its allowable limits. But it could
actually be impossible to control if you
were to stall the airplane during this
condition. If you're wondering why that
is, I want you to think about how our
airplane is balanced. Remember, the
aircraft's tail is used to balance out
the airplane. But what's one more thing
we need in order for the tail to be
effective? Yeah, the tail needs air
flowing over the top and bottom of it so
it can push the nose up and down. And
this means that when we're flying at low
air speeds, the tail, just like all the
other controls, is going to have less
control authority. Let's say the nose of
our airplane was pitched way up like
this, and we stall the airplane. Under
normal circumstances, this wouldn't be a
big deal because we just pitch down and
break the stall by reducing the angle of
attack, wouldn't we? But if the center
of gravity was too far back when this
happened, you might not actually be able
to push the nose back down because the
weight is too far back and the tail
doesn't have enough control authority to
overcome that unbalanced weight. In this
case, the airplane could potentially
fall all the way to the ground, tail
first. As you can see, the center of
gravity is extremely important when
we're considering the controllability of
an airplane. But what would happen if we
move the center of gravity too far
forward? As a general rule, stability
increases as the center of gravity moves
forward, as long as the tail can create
enough downforce to balance out the
airplane. But what would happen if we
move the center of gravity too far
forward? Well, if we moved it too far up
here, then the tail would not be able to
create enough downforce to keep the
airplane balanced. In most cases, the
first place you would notice this would
be during the takeoff roll because you
wouldn't be able to pitch the nose of
your airplane up because the nose is so
heavy. Boy, that'd be scary, wouldn't
it? Stalls wouldn't necessarily be a
problem, though, because the nose is
really heavy in this situation. This
means that we should have plenty of tail
authority to pitch down and reduce the
angle of attack during a stall. But
climbing or pitching up might be a
problem because there may not be enough
wind going over the tail to move the
nose of the airplane up. Okay, so
stability is the first thing that
affects our ability to control the
airplane, but there's actually a few
other things that affects our aircraft's
controllability. So, let's go ahead and
talk about those. Now, we've already
been talking a little bit about this,
but I'm going to go ahead and bring it
up again because I believe that it's the
most important thing that affects
controllability. What is the one thing
we need for the control surfaces to move
our airplane? Yeah, we need relative
wind moving over them, don't we? I mean,
you can't roll an airplane that's just
sitting there on the ground when there's
no wind, can you? No, you can't. You've
got to have relative wind. And the
faster the relative wind is, the more
control authority you have, or the more
controllable your airplane is. That's
one reason why air speed is so
important. The faster you can get an
airplane to move, the more controllable
it is, because there's more air flowing
over and under the control surfaces. In
fact, this is a big reason why we teach
you slow flight during your flight
training. We want you to see how mushy
the controls are when you're flying
really, really slow. Another thing that
affects controllability is angle of
attack. Keep in mind, angle of attack is
directly related to these other things
we've already been talking about, but
it's important to consider because angle
of attack plays a big role in the
controllability of your airplane. Now,
unless your mom moves around the
airplane, the center of gravity doesn't
typically move during flight. But if we
change the angle of attack by pitching
the nose of the airplane down, something
really interesting happens. Anytime we
pitch the nose of the airplane down and
speed up, the center of pressure moves
back on the wing a little bit. This in
turn causes the center of gravity to be
further away from the center of lift
even though the CG doesn't actually
change. Because of this, and because the
airplane speeds up when the nose is
lowered, this causes the airplane to be
more stable because the tail is creating
more downforce as well. This would be a
lot like balancing a pencil on your
finger. Which one of these do you think
would be easier to balance? Yeah, this
long one, right? And the same thing
happens when the center of gravity is
further away from our balancing point
and the tail is creating more downforce.
And if this is true when we pitch the
nose of the airplane down, then the
opposite must be true when we increase
the angle of attack on an airplane.
Anytime we pitch the nose of the
airplane up, the center of lift moves
forward. Once again, the CG doesn't
change, but the CG is now closer to the
center of lift because the center of
lift moved forward. And because we
pitched the nose of the airplane up, our
tail is creating less downforce because
we're moving slower. This is a lot like
widening your stance when you're
standing. Do you think you're going to
have more control over your balance if
you have a wider or narrower stance?
Yeah, a wider stance is better, isn't
it? The last way we can affect
controllability is through power
changes. Anytime the engine is moving
the propeller, air will flow over and
under the aircraft control surfaces. And
this air is part of some of the wind
that makes up relative wind. But this
particular part of relative wind
actually has a name. We call it the
slipstream. Anytime wind from the
slipstream moves over and under the
control surfaces of an airplane, the
pilot will have more control over the
aircraft when this happens. Keep in
mind, some airplanes have control
surfaces that are outside of the
slipstream. And this means that those
particular controls will not be affected
by power changes. One particular example
of this is a tetail aircraft like this
Piper Tomahawk. On aircraft like this,
the tail is not affected anytime you
make power changes because it's not
getting any air from the slipstream.
Now, even in this airplane, once the
airplane slows down, the tail is going
to be creating less downforce. So, when
this happens, the nose will drop, but
not until the airplane slows down or you
go from a headwind to a tailwind. And
that's important for you to remember
because if you're flying an airplane
with a standard tail, this means that
anytime you reduce the power, the nose
is going to want to drop on you. So, if
you don't want that to happen, then you
need to be anticipating it. And here's a
little bonus for you. On the C130, they
place the engines directly in front of
the wings. And this is cool because
pushing up the power gives this airplane
instant lift as well. In fact, they call
this the blown wing. And this allows
this aircraft to climb like a beast
whenever the pilot pushes up the
throttles to max power. And then this
extra power also gives the pilot a nice
boost of aileron authority in this plane
as well because those are right there in
the slipstream. So if you want a little
more control over your airplane, these
are the things you should be thinking
about and this knowledge is going to
make you a better pilot. For example,
let's say you stalled your airplane and
you lost control authority of the tail.
Yes, breaking the stall is the most
important part of recovery. But what's
something else you can use to help you
get more control over the airplane
during a stall? Yeah, by adding power,
this can send wind over and under the
tail of the aircraft through the
slipstream, which can help you regain
control of the aircraft. That's why I
like to use the Air Force motto of max,
relax, roll during a stall. Yes,
breaking the stall is the most important
step in recovering from a stall, but you
can easily do all three of these at the
same time. And adding power at the same
time that you're breaking a stall will
give you more control over the aircraft,
unless of course you're flying a tetail
like the old tomahawk. And that is
everything you need to know about
controllability. In the next lesson,
we're going to be talking about flaps.
And that's a super important lesson that
you don't want to miss out on. And don't
forget, if you're enjoying this totally
free training and you need an
endorsement for the FAA written exam, be
sure to check out my premium course at
free pilotraining.net. That's only $50
over there. So, thanks for watching. See
you.